we could not both know my cat Lizzie
back on land wait come back frightening
Walters hold on usually I don't
understand how our teeth are so so white
so yeah so don't James you say anyway
only we can fight against an awful idea
with an equally awesome awful idea yeah
that's a privet guy yeah
and then I'll say turn left which are
left
and see you know a giant monster that he
was alone and
one two three ah ah where we look at
that TOEFL yeah oh yeah like four yeah
yeah big they'll be my yeah and yeah
that will cut there will look at what
the rest is gonna be so um don't shave
Malcolm it will Queen yeah I mean for
that you announcement say yeah go
Malcolm
I can see me yeah Oh
my god ha muck amuck make your mind yeah
sorry oh this Quran say Matt the money
Malcolm
I mean you've been in Star Trek critic
videos before it's like that um it's
good to have you back yes absolutely
yeah and um this time we've got a andre
from black nerd comedy here uh he met
him before yeah a few times
who's in the nerd movie that was the
first time when I ever met him actually
and uh I didn't know much about him at
the time but he entered the audition and
Shai first time I ever saw him was in
the audition actually he actually I did
meet him at the audition because I was
with you look at all the tanks and he
seemed to have like a lot of the best
reactions are there's like oh yeah and
everybody liked it pretty to the cross
were like oh yeah describe me how to use
them
it was a short scene but it was in the
the video game store when I'm telling
him not to play that this game and then
he's like oh I gotta fight I just
remember we were both cracking up that
whole time they're trying to film that
uh and then uh then I seen him again on
a couple conventions I know Comic Con
this past year
oh I seen my two adventures this year so
now pluses I've seen three times this
year that's awesome yeah since we've
crossed paths before yeah it's pretty
cool um so would you say you laid a
guess here similar fanaticism when it
comes to turtles in Turtles yeah
definitely I could see that for sure
mm-hmm
there's a lot of turtles fanatics around
here I can tell you the turtles are
strong in this in this whole circuit
sync the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
Jean is strong yeah amongst this crowd
but uh yeah do you see yourself making
any uh other big projects coming up or
is that something that you can Illya as
always just what is the question I mean
it's it's a problem of having too many
ideas and trust you okay which one do I
want to do the most so you got a narrow
it down because it just comes down to
where like you know when you're picking
you like a college you know you have all
these ideas lined up and I would do this
one then I'm gonna do that one I'm gonna
do this and then it's like ten years
later like okay well I'm not gonna
realistically be able to every I hear
about it
hey choose wisely see sandwich one is
more viable and pretty much the
webseries like that's more than enough
to keep you occupied so it's hard to
like yeah yeah definitely because I
remember when you guys did all the you
know as did your anniversary sales for
like so big data completely like Doug
was saying like it's like it's a whole
thing on top of another thing so it's oh
yeah it's just it's that hard thing a
final I know I feel like probably oh
absolutely yeah yeah I'm hoping we get
some more anniversary stuff in yeah
without spoiling anything we are
thinking of one but we like to do one
for 10 yeah I said that Qi is before so
it's not oh good I mean I liked we are
looking into it we do have some ideas
and stuff so we are definitely looking
into that but I mean nothing submit this
is like it is what we like to do we're
seeing if it's possible to do it wait
United me P well you heard it right here
for sure
the behind the scenes and they're gonna
make a that was james rolfe everybody's
awesome babies awesome you know reduce
each other yeah yeah so how did you meet
Doug we met at a convention um thing was
in Detroit
I believe Midwest Media Expo I think is
what we know that was the first I think
that was the first time we actually met
in person we we had communicated
beforehand right that was the first time
that we met and was shortly after Doug
and James at the there Turtles first
hurdle movie right right right so yeah
so we had talked then it was like oh we
should do something together
but they had just did Turtles he was
like was very interesting anything else
I was like I like Smurfs yeah and so
then we are like looks at this Murph's
movie so that was
what happens I came out here well
actually I was already out here for a
convention that he was also at and it so
I just stayed longer and then we we did
the Smurfs movie and worked and the rest
is cinematic history
yes YouTube worlds colliding but I have
been watching Doug pretty much since he
began
Doug and I emulate some of the first
people I watched that's crazy on well on
YouTube and then on their own sites and
all that stuff so yeah let's sort of
like the runners who kind of
inspirations I started everybody can't
really tell Doug that cuz he gets a big
hit look you're my inspiration with my
inspiration my ego that's that's in case
you daughters don't know that if you
inflate the ego he just shows up but
that is it was like cuz I I used to make
videos like every once in a while just
like I'm gonna do a fun little short
thing and it wasn't till I was watching
people like them I was like oh wait he
would do this on a regular regular basis
so that's what kind of got me involved I
want to do that so you can get paid for
your bullshit yes but that was like old
school like I just got in the partner
program so it was like I got five cents
for the entire month oh I gotta make a
hundred dollars just to get this money
oh yeah yeah and now I make a hundred
and one just enough just enough oh you
kids your dreams he come true no but it
was great no it's great yeah these these
guys they're from awesome comics they do
the show awesome comics they discuss
everything comes book related and
they're awesome it was really title
suggest okay we are awesome like I was
just recently on an episode with you
guys yeah
and we should have a DBZ episode I think
we should I feel like mache cuz like
you're silly we have a lot of people
left watch it very much because he
transcends me it's like we're gonna get
some buying sins but we'll pick up on my
taxes and ah you can't trust him
oh come on he's not making the film he's
just financing it yeah you wait to
notice I'm here guys has such a pretty
movie you might even touch it sure would
you fingerprints all over it good when
he says the idea custom is cuz I've got
this long shotgun yeah but less wait
till after he says you can't cross
Canada start okay you don't have to do
the ahh
okay I've just clearing my throat
ready ready yep actually
huh
okay cool let's get how can this be bop
yeah so weird it's not like that but
these beep I got a laugh out of that I
left them like everything in it half the
time they were good half the time feels
like shot ah I forgot about that timer
yeah uh Dean's movie over like you're
doing the mind without me haha so
Malcolm I think I'll have you justify
why people see your Mountain oh yes I'll
have you had you come out from behind
here you just gonna say hey guys what do
you say we talk about our dicks and make
fart jokes all day tomorrow yeah
and you can just sort of like yeah just
serve dragon on like that Center um yeah
I think we look at his hands
was it I don't know I said yeah we
disdain of this appointment you can
still around cuz I actually do have one
of these oh they actually it's hilarious
home fingers yeah like that oh this is
no no no leave her on the rest haven't
grown into my rhino for Nia um yeah I'd
say yeah sort of look where she is I
think when you come out now go ahead
come out and look in her direction
yeah and and if you should probably be
right
I think yeah yeah it should mean extreme
but yeah pretty much what they did
rolling hey why was it y'all ready and
action
hey guys what do you say we talk about
our dicks make fart jokes all day be
buck great y'all just got the faces on
to the mommy uh yes AJ the carpet does
match in case you're wondering I don't
think in giant purple people eater
that's what the color oh all right is it
the the carpet does match Oh like was
the strike what's happening Oh different
octaves oh oh it's called an acting milk
yeah yeah try it sometime Oh
I usually reaction my walk-in about the
carpet matches so that perform like okay
uh yeah here you know where the movie so
you should work in I will okay oh here
uh Walt oh it's get you in with the yeah
Schneider scarf dude
yeah oh he had a police yeah we have a
dancing area we need everybody take it
you guys want everybody yeah okay well
well today I went to come in here in the
night room decoration okay fuck yeah and
you look like all right all right say
something nice yeah see those yeah
you've also got the most you could drop
your shoulders that yeah perfect okay
yeah that looks
Oh now is there waiting on the hopper a
description is there way to getting a
little bit more very good yep that's
perfect okay um can you still talk now
the tiniest thing yet just emotions and
relationship just I'm holding this
Christine's okay yeah well yeah I think
but yeah we should some case okay am I
looking rising cameras yeah pretty much
it's just that second line they have
using one I love destroying things is
fine results an obstruction of your
species
yeah I was thinking that I mean I am
Ribbit's cuz I mean I said oh yeah I'm
gonna take a headlock just research ah
see so oh oh are you filming filming
filming don't cross the streams yeah
it's behind the scenes section below the
world ain't ready for all these behind
the scenes
somebody seen some day maybe you're not
ready on that campaign so so thank you
behind the behind the CSS this is the
behind minds of behind my scenes that's
a highly receiving Malcolm's answer
what's got my behind behind
yeah but I do not want a backstage but
everything that you sounds like a point
so that's Adam
like randomly like after for murder
Oh crazy is a hobby
good I am again their teacher is RAM no
I uh having a version of bets now ever
since the season premiere of walking
dead sisters who I don't watch Walking
Dead oh you guys oh I know we got a star
oh yeah yeah I think I surprised me
though I didn't know there's a rain
mechanic yeah yeah it was like kinda one
time camera I mean I knew what was
coming but I didn't know they were gonna
do with that hardcore like chill the
fuck out shit now I really I see the
scene yeah do know it is pretty little
um its money but over here yet like
hamburger meat
yeah yeah so eating rice right there
socket a broken though he writes mother
ah so your eye lines gonna be here
Tamara oh and there's information black
moon is keeping us but he only responds
to women dressed in Harley Quinn
uniforms accommodate us no but Michael
Bay said you would know for a season
Harvey Quinn wait I'm not Megan Fox I
can't be easily replaced if I don't know
what you want no switch Ayanna good here
yeah look in here uh yes all right and
I'll just give you the leading yup no of
course not now which baseball that looks
better
that's our Tamara okay hold it there
good look over there again Palin as soon
as I say action is when you turn and
wink okay and action
welcome I love your face what you're
doing out like I know that's the pieces
from the gears from yeah divine we do it
uh that workout hard this doesn't work
there so yeah pretty much gonna be like
where uh yeah is there and you gotta
come in both you Malcolm you say guys
you're a bride defeated Godzilla before
yeah how would you how well look even
bigger monsters outside and we need your
help to stop it hmm I don't know
police chief what do you think it was oh
my god should I stay away from this this
way I I think probably from like hey
over here I mean just like almost like a
cartoon just like alright Jesse Lee
chief what do you think you you come in
yes oh where are we oh they're real they
don't know what they're talking about it
makes me so angry I want to bulb my eyes
out bubble my head and disgust huh she
is the police chief yeah she's in a
position for a reason but you can see
the monster to feed it before how can
you say oh ok screw you guys I have a
city to save this is ridiculous
none of you have any idea what you're
doing you're an insult to hard-working
law enforcers everywhere she's tamarin I
liked you better earlier and then Ayanna
you can definitely tell me you're a
sublease yes so when you guys switch
like swap places yeah yeah that's rich
again yeah and you're just saying I
think we'll probably view with the bats
to it just like you well thanks guys and
then we'll just track in on you again
and you'll just look in wink and I'll
say your line and you lean in and it's
ok I'm here so she can look like that I
just never smile just sylveon
it's ok yeah just everything I mean you
can like bobble it all the time I plan I
just feel like yes pretty much I mean
you can just the frenches know you're
just very
sure you're very stiff but you're also
is very obvious you're that damn like
what a waste we make it a little bit
more sore do it
yes like that yeah that is perfect you
just got limited can I say that one more
time
oh yes Andrew so you've seen the you
sing Suicide Squad right mm-hmm
sorry yeah like how'd you feel like how
they handle the crocodile oh jeez just
cry I think I killed rock yeah kid it
was all I'm sorry it won't be as far as
like looks like his character yeah like
I go like it got progressively like okay
this character must definitely be a
black man that turned into oh but they
had wolf bet the dead shot so even now
as long as you have to which okay okay
being white there's a theme of the day
and your guides yeah Tamra nobody has
more respect for women
yeah cities every single one of them all
right guys guys I'm gonna go next try
one yeah okay so go ahead yeah start
more that way
but you can see the monster I defeat it
before there's literally no reason not
to trust us
I have checked the authenticity of our
eyes and they are not clean oh why don't
you check the authenticity okay screw
you guys I got a city to save I am so
upset with you you're a disgrace to all
policemen everywhere just accept you
stay there yeah and she's a woman so it
makes it a little confusing
Sacha's women matter Tamra I don't I
have more respect for name with broads
man right Oh
honestly uh with that one Tamra even if
you don't read just sort of keep it
going a little bit you just talk like
this and you're just angry you're going
on and on the blah blah blah and this is
just a disgrace but the line is this is
ridiculous now if you have any idea what
you're doing you're an insult to
hard-working law enforcers everywhere
okay awesome
so we'll take you from okay screw you
guys all right
mm I get it I want to be ready mom okay
sorry sorry
all right yeah okay whenever you're a
Malkin okay screw you guys I got a city
of save honestly this is a ridiculous
you guys have no idea what you're
talking about you're a disgrace to law
enforcers everywhere
hey Ana get in there okay what's the
line well thanks guys yeah okay jeez
damn right I liked you a lot better
earlier well thanks guys thank you it's
okay I'm here so she can look like that
yeah that's the line a broken just
couldn't even get to just dumb sorry
guys it just destroyed me all right uh I
don't think that was the one I asked if
we could switch those lines oh okay
that's why I was like I choked I don't
know what happened okay uh yeah oh yeah
that's fine all right okay ready to
forget how good I was an arrow ready to
forget how awesome I was an arrow ready
to forget how much you liked me an arrow
okay
and then oh no gender
so faxed our Stockman in the Foot Clan
ambush the truck to break them out or
just say so Baxter Stockman and the Foot
Clan ambush the truck to break him out
and the Foot Clan er actual ninjas this
time no guns
that was cool gotta give him a point for
that oh yes we can do that then I just
drop this with actually just actually
why do they even need the Shires I'm
pretty damn good without him
yeah but the turtles arrived with some
new toys unmarked but the turtles
arrived with some new toys okay and this
is gonna be the nunchuck arms eye and
we're all excited just okay that's
awesome
I'll be like 1 2 3 like and they're
going up good
oh the coolest thing lasso clothes thing
lasts only a few seconds like get used
to that all right so ready mm-hmm
and action okay that's awesome well uh
one two three and they're gone the
coolest thing lasts only a few seconds
get used to that the useful life is so I
don't think about your think about it
all what are we doing guys I do it here
what is this hey Tom please just still
talk about Ninja Turtles years later
hater
where's why don't we make this why are
we never happy says happy if we just
don't we just try to make a movie and
make it like perfect but we don't have
like the budget or anything like
everything just falls off a smell like a
beer anniversary uh okay uh good we'll
do one more for safety
let's go a little bit more do oh oh yeah
okay ready action
okay that was awesome one two three and
it's gone
Kohl's thing only lasts a few seconds
get used to that get used to life just
love we need to love the pudding one
action and they're gone
coolest thing only lasts a few seconds
get used to that get used to life every
time they liver that's like like it used
to life a bitch okay at some point you
just go shredder
I'm just like if that is your real name
Lana said if that is your real name if
that is your real name
alright
but Baxter uses a teleportation device
to bean shredder away resulting in him
Dow but backs are uses a teleportation
device to bean shredder away resulting
in him somehow meeting up with Krang
great one morally bad person but Baxter
uses a teleportation device to being
shredder away resulting in him somehow
meeting up with Krang we do it one more
time jerk differently hmm but bachelor
uses a teleportation device to beam
shredder away resulting in him somehow
meeting up with everybody's favorite
alien brain Krang just capri the song
cheapest make
again
what did you get to meet him at retro
con yeah cool nice yeah oh so fun
I always don't like a quick high but I
was cool with that he did things there
and now it's time to play why this is
awesome but not as awesome as we thought
all right hmm sure follow um Oh anywhere
we're gonna explain why it's like it's
cool to be frank but how come this isn't
quite as awesome as we want it to be
it's still awesome because it wasn't
done 20 years ago
Yeah right correct
um so big because it was not done 20
years ago waiting on this whole thing
dude okay let's see yeah I hate the bald
head they change that why did he do that
hmm um Krang looks pretty good even with
the modern-day updates but for some
reason they give his body this cluttered
mechanical head instead of the
traditional bald head from the cartoon I
wouldn't mind so much except in the
trailers they clearly did give him the
bald head so why change it did actually
do that in the triplets really change it
in the in the trailer you seen what the
bald head he looks great he looks like
he looks like a updated version of the
original guy yeah and then they change
her for the movie I have no idea why she
got to watch that trailer again yeah hey
I'll say it one more time though because
they didn't do it 20 years ago Krang
looks pretty good even with the
modern-day updates but for some reason
they even with the monitor you okay
Krang looks pretty good even with the
modern-day digital update about to say I
said crime looks pretty good even as a
digital whatever I just had was crying
looks pretty good even with the
modern-day updates but for some reason
they give his body this cluttered
chemical head instead of the traditional
bald head from the cartoons I wouldn't
mind so much except in the trailers they
clearly did give him the bald head so I
change it and then you're like no no
that's not the real like we're still
playing the game car right uh yeah maybe
red okay no no that's not the reason
good try another one no no that's wrong
no no you keep breaking James like you'd
see yourself like just keep repairing
yourself
okay I'm rock solid
I'm rock steady yeah yeah rule no no
that is so sorry
now I'm rock steady all right room no no
that is not the reason the real reason
is because crane barely gets an
introduction before he jumps into
immediately throwing a ton of plot at us
like a ton great one more cuz I do the
real reason the real reason is because
the real reason is because Krang barely
gets an introduction before he jumps
into immediately throwing a ton of plot
at us like a ton big issue is his voice
and this one's did again
but no that's not the reason either the
big reason is his voice good Charma more
wrong the big issue is his body was
there anywhere all right okay hmm don't
be wrong the big issue making games with
the wrong looking thing is a wrong
you're like double rule this new flavor
of gum double wrong nasty critic why is
this one it's just that's the big as you
hear not even us it's just the condition
oh my god
oh you're imitating like high school
student capacity all right here we go
guesses been this has been our vote PSA
okay scoot a little bit witness the
court Nick chairs are farting together
no that's not the reason either
the big issue is his voice I'm just like
I can't do it it really is just you I
think I smudged my
you